[Música]
es un gran placer que estamos reunidos
aquí en el estudio 26 de radio canadá
para presentarles este programa su
programa de todos los viernes canadá en
las américas café correspondiente a este
viernes 21 de febrero en vivo y en
directo por facebook live youtube
nuestro sitio internet y reseñas punto o
sea y nuestra aplicación de la cual les
hablaremos un poquitito más tarde hoy me
acompaña aquí en el estudio luis laborda
nos encontramos un bocado viernes y
además como ya se han dado cuenta allá
al otro lado de la mesa se encuentra
cara carmina con ella vamos a pasar todo
este programa y vamos a conversar
lo que hace cada camina que a mi juicio
es muy bonito lo que hace cara
bienvenida a radio canadá internacional
gracias por invita igualmente estamos
todos muy contentos y bueno pero primero
y antes que todo un caluroso a todos
ustedes allá que se encuentran del otro
lado del micrófono y de las cámaras un
cordial saludo y esperamos que este
programa sea de su agrado muchísimas
gracias por su alta fidelidad y por su
agradable compañía
y ipad también de alta fidelidad
pero antes de entrar de lleno en este
castor cibernético vamos a vamos a
hablar un poco de
como de costumbre todos los viernes de
algo que les haya llamado la atención
una efeméride por ejemplo de algo que no
hayamos conversado en el pasado pero que
queremos mostrarles hoy a hacerle
escuchar y ver más bien a nuestros
oyentes y en louis la semana pasada
justamente nosotros hablábamos de una
ranita se recuerdan de la ranita que
encontraron aves en un pimiento o en un
pimiento esta semana cambiamos de los
batracios y nos fuimos hacia los
insectos y al parecer encontraron una
langosta en una ensalada aparentemente
la comida en los últimos tiempos viene
presentando sorpresas
con agregados enriquecidas tiene como
los huevitos quintano con sorpresita
dentro de su masa y vemos ya las
imágenes del pequeño vídeo que han hecho
quienes se encontraron en este insecto
paseándose por su ensalada ahí tienes
una langosta comiendo una langosta como
le dicen en
agentina y en algunos otros países más
pero nosotros la conocemos más como
saltamontes o no sé en méxico como le
dicen este saltamontes
la diferencia es según el tamaño y según
el largo de las alas puede ser una
langosta un saltamontes no es
exactamente lo mismo si nosotros
nosotros en santiago del estero en
argentina hay épocas de plaga de
langostas de ese tipo de langostas no de
los blogs por la que se sube cuando es
para mí una langosta yo la veo ya
preparada en mira dato se deja con un
poquito de limón al lado de un poquito
de mantequilla se va a cortar pasábamos
en sal del estero es brutal el calor que
se vive y bueno y son plátanos entonces
bueno cuando empieza a bajar el sol
empiezan a salir estos bichitos que
hacen un ruido extraordinario entre
estos bichitos y los coyuyos bichitos
que pueden ser que yo tenía y nos
divertimos en el tiempo cuando había no
había teléfonos celulares y uno salía a
jugar en lo que hacíamos era juntar
de langostas y yo llegué a tener 232
langostas en mi caso era un juego por
supuesto y después de este cuento por
los langostas los que sufrían con
nosotros no vio los chinos salta salta y
están encontraron un paquete de ensalada
que compró una familia de la localidad
de sanya sant muy cerca de aquí esa
ensalada que proviene de vegetales
cosechados en los eeuu al sur de la
frontera con canadá pero que es el
paquete procesada y empaquetada aquí en
una planta que se encuentra la monterrey
y aquí en la ribera sur de material yo
pensaba que eso venía ya empaquetado no
sé para qué estás acá vienen los
containers y después lo empaqueta al
menos en este caso lo que yo aprendí con
este caso es que hay un sistema para la
detección de elementos extraños en este
tipo de las proteínas en este caso la
empresa que empaqueta estas ensaladas
utiliza un sistema de detección con
así que no sé exactamente cómo es el
procedimiento pero detecta todo lo que
no contenga clorofila que se pueda
encontrar dentro del paquete así que
anda saber de dónde se impregnó la
clorofila de esta langosta pero que
aparte aparte de verde estaba comiendo
la señora cuando iba a terminar el
paquete pues ya habían consumido tres
cuartas partes del contenido a mi me
encontró con que algo se movía en el
interior del envoltorio
pero era la famosa langosta que como se
pudo ver una de las fotos que ya pasó en
su amigo pierre terminó perdiendo la
vida en esta aventura
aunque bueno cómo terminó la ranita de
la que habíamos hablado la última vez si
había muchísimo es verdad le pusieron
billy beane ya la bautizaron la
alimentaron y la cuidaron durante varios
días pero una de las mañanas cuando
fueron a acercarse al recipiente donde
no vino
al darle de comer encontraron con que
vida había pasado al otro mundo
fue menos cruel que con la ranita porque
la ranita
le hicieron una autopsia para saber si
murió de la autopsia identificaron el
nombre de la escencia para saber si no
había por ahí algún virus o algo que no
fuera adicción a contaminar no porque
tenemos ahora como que alergia
williams señor diseño barbaridad vida
también le decimos paco paco paco paco
claro si hay otros nombres también soy
ahora no me acuerdo pero encontré vivir
numerosos nombres en internet y cuando y
creo que si no me equivoco con santiago
del estero en argentina cuando vienen
así de a montones no le dicen la tucura
es como la plaga la playa que si no me
equivoco cuando me acuerdo haber
escuchado tucura exactamente no me
acuerdo por qué pero ahora cuando venían
las langostas y javier gonzález perdón y
nos dice saludos cordiales para todos
pablo luis leonardo si la invitada o una
felicitación para pablo por el programa
especial del día mundial de la radio
me gustó mucho muchas gracias muchas
gracias y le quería enviar yo por mi
parte también un cabo un saludo muy
cordial a william senior que es un amigo
de infancia el que dice que en
barranquilla crecimos en la misma calle
la calle 48 en barranquilla y
efectivamente los pac opacos pues
andamos persiguiendo los paco paco pero
son más chiquititos allá que son más
críticos y muchas gracias a javier
también hay a un fiel oyente de radio
canal internacional leonardo gimeno fm
efemérides por supuesto la de semana ida
dije qué efemérides de quién se murió
quien vivió no no ni siquiera vamos a
decir los días internacionales hay
muchos no nos conoce
y en este caso bueno hay varios el 20 de
febrero hay 3 días internacionales
el día internacional del gato
tiene dos gatos tiene el nombre de su
gato
me impresionó a bordo
jajajajaja
y después está el día mundial de la
justicia social el 20 de febrero también
y el día internacional de la pipa a
aquellos fumadores pipas tienen un
diente materna del 20 droguett es colega
diego creo que era mezclado en alguna
vez intenté cuando quería dejar el otro
vicio pasé a la pipa y andaría va a está
muy guardada de recuerdo la pipa el 21
de febrero el día internacional de la
lengua materna y el día internacional
del guía de turismo si kato los guías de
turismo saludos y felicitaciones sí
señor hoy entonces exacto el 20 de
febrero como mañana estamos en línea
pero no estamos en vivo y en directo día
mundial de la
y luego yo lo que dice en su esencia
del encéfalo y el día del pensamiento
scout si no es precisamente la mejor
semana para los scouts pero no exacto y
el 23 de febrero el domingo comienza en
muchas partes de nuestra queridísima
américa latina el carnaval el carnaval
del cual estaba hablando nos justamente
de william y está acá barranquilla
prendida hoy es viernes y bueno ya
aunque lleguen barranquilla ya están en
carnavales desde hace como dos meses más
o menos cierto william bueno y yo por mi
parte
les quiero recordar y les quiero hablar
de un evento muy importante que
tiene lugar la semana próxima y es el 75
aniversario de radio canadá
internacional radio canadá internacional
fue creado el 25 de febrero de 1945 y
este este martes próximo el 25 de
febrero cumplimos 75 años ya ha habido
pues toda una transformación claro está
desde ese 1945 cuando se creó radio
canadá internacional hasta hoy en día
estuvimos sobre todo en la onda corta y
aquí hicimos años digamos que la
comunicación ha cambiado tanto en aquel
momento bueno esta fue el decir este fue
el sitio interna que hicimos para los 70
james en este caso vamos por los 75 y
vamos por más
la historia es que durante justamente el
transcurso la historia ha cambiado han
cambiado las necesidades en cambiado los
medios de comunicación y la manera de
comunicarnos en aquel tiempo y cuando
fue creada la radio
nacional era el auge de las radios en
onda corta y tenían un porqué el hecho
de las transmisiones a larga distancia
que no eran tan comunes y la onda corta
ayudaba mucho en ese sentido en este
caso también hay que recordar que el
porqué del nacimiento ahora de canadá
internacional tiene que ver con la
información para la época de la guerra
mis años para informar a los soldados
canadienses que se encontraban en el
frente en europa para que supieran qué
estaba pasando acá exacto y entonces era
una manera muy especial de informarse lo
que pasaba del otro lado del mundo donde
no había el internet que tenemos ahora
entonces bueno en esa transformación han
ido cambiando las cosas y a partir del
año 2012 radio qhana internacional del
24 de junio del 2006 ahora me recuerdo
perfectamente porque fui yo el que apagó
la luz el último programa que se
transmitió en onda corta en radio canadá
internacional fue
el castor mensajero que fue un domingo y
lo hicimos solíamos grabar el castor
durante la semana el viernes y lo
difundimos después el domingo pero esa
última estuvimos todos presentes ahí y
bueno pues me tocó a mí presentar el
último programa el último programa de la
era de la onda de la onda corre exacto
porque después bueno la transformación
implicó este este cambio a este nuevo
medio del medio que en el que estamos
hoy
qué es internet qué bueno en realidad
cambia la manera de informarse porque la
gente si está en el medio de la nada
puede conectarse internet y ver lo que
pasa del otro lado del mundo sin ningún
problema cosa que hace 75 años era
imposible bueno era posible en la medida
en que la onda corta aunque tú
estuvieras en la selva con un radiecito
de pilas podía seguir y escuchar la
radio océano particularmente el recuerdo
que tengo de una onda corta mi papá
tenía una vieja tonomac que recibía onda
corta y escuchábamos radio qhana
internacional en inglés en francés y en
español
paola va inglés y español por supuesto y
francés solo por la dicha de escuchar
algún otro idioma y mi papá escuchaba
también programas de la deutsche welle y
escuchaba programas de radio nederland
the voice of america del recibir radio
francia internacional y en otras lenguas
cada una de esas que acaba de nombrar
las grandes radios que tuvieron
presencia internacional en la onda corta
transmitían en muchas lenguas como pasó
aquí en radio internacional que en la
primera época
llegarán 23 -la en tres lenguas
diferentes louis si yo también tengo mis
anécdotas para contar de hecho recuerdo
que desde muy pequeño bueno mi relación
con la radio muy particular porque mi
relación con la radio pasa sobre todo a
través de mi padre que fue un periodista
y fue quien me hizo conocer el medio
pero en el caso específico de la onda
corta me recuerdo siendo muy pequeño no
sé por qué pero fue así escuchar
transmisiones de radio la habana y de
hecho tengo muy presente alguna vez un
discurso en vivo y en directo de horas y
horas de duración de fidel castro
hablando a fidel hablando mucho tiempo y
menos de seis horas y de escuchar
también a la radio moscú me apasionaba
escuchar otro idioma corazón rica
trabajada y en un momento dado momento
fue trabajar a moscú también pero era un
mundo tan extraño tan distante tan
atractivo y tan distinto con aquellas
viejas características locutoras de la
vieja radio vamos a jugar
en épocas de la a una unión soviética
que era muy muy apasionante todo eso es
material precioso que supongo que
desarrollaremos la semana próxima cuando
nos aboquemos al tema de los 75 años del
radio canadá internacional y de la
importancia que la onda corta tuvo
durante tantos años para esta emisora
también discutíamos de hecho hoy que si
bien la forma de transmisión cambian las
formas de recepción también
no el consumo en sí mismo de hecho hoy
hablamos de un par de anécdotas que
reflejan como en algunos lugares en
distintos lugares del planeta pero
específicamente en el caso nuestro de
américa latina' el consumo de la radio
con la finalidad que el oyente le otorga
a una la radio no ha cambiado tanto hay
usos que siguen siendo que siguen
permaneciendo a lo largo del tiempo a
que el mensaje social aquella función
social que jugaba a la radio y que bueno
que sigue jugando aún todavía hoy en día
en algunos lugares de américa de
aplicación inmediata en la vida
cotidiana de la gente que no pasa por
los grandes temas que supuestamente se
debaten y se difunden a través de los
grandes medios de comunicación es cierto
que las grandes emisoras han modificado
su contenido y el público al que se
dirigen pero hay todavía pequeños medios
que se incumpliendo cerró social al cual
mostré acaba de referir que tiene que
ver con la vida cotidiana de la gente y
que no ha cambiado
de ninguna manera si yo me acuerdo pues
ya se hace aproximadamente 15 17 años
estoy aquí en canadá más antes 17
inviernos antes trabajaba vivía en la
ciudad de san luis en argentina y
trabajaba trabaje tuve el gusto de
trabajar también en radio nacional de
san luis la emisora de radio nacional
argentina pero en en su oficina de san
luís y nosotros el domingo a la mañana
teníamos un programa que recibimos los
mensajes de la gente es decir por
ejemplo doña rosa espera al tío benito
que va a pasar a tal hora por tal cruce
para que le debe los remedios para la
abuela y ese tipo de cosas eran
importantes y uno decía
en realidad la información es más
importante y esa gente la radio para
ellos
era eso era eso la historia de la
necesidad de lo social de lo que lo que
me hace falta comentarle a los parientes
del otro del otro costado de la
provincia qué
la abuela estaba muy enferma o que tenía
un problema con sus hijos o que iban a
mandar al hijo para estudiar hasta local
lugar entonces ese tipo de decencia de
la radio en algunos lugares como decía
luis sigue sucediendo y sigue
funcionando así en la radio era
portadora de buenas y malas noticias es
aquella época tan bueno como se habrán
podido dar cuenta el paloma martínez
acaba de unirse aquí como por arte de
magia apareció bienvenida palomita
estará muy contenta de estar por acá
disculpen la desaparición no tranquila
tranquila estamos conversando haciendo
alusión a viejos recuerdos de la radio y
todo eso no sé tú si en cuestiones de
viejos recuerdos de la radio debes tener
también alguna anécdota por algo vencida
como viejos viejos no puede o no pues
tengo recuerdos de mi trabajo en la
radio de mi experiencia con la radio
también cuando era niña siempre
escuchábamos radio en la casa de sus
cierto siempre nos acompañó en todos
momentos a un momento pero también la
relación que uno va desarrollando con la
radio cuando uno trabaja dentro
ella es maravilloso yo creo que para mí
es un siempre un privilegio tener un
micrófono enfrente y poder decir cosas y
poder tener la posibilidad de investigar
de entrevistar de hablar con gente
interesante cada vez que nos ponemos a
trabajar a escuchar radio en la casa me
hizo acordar en algún momento lo conté
cuando yo era niño en la casa de mis
padres había 12 receptores de radio
consumidos
cara carmina tú tienes algún recuerdo
que nos quieres contar así grandemente
la radio mi abuela mi abuela escuchaba
todo el día a la radio tenía una pequeña
radio que parecía una televisión
chiquitita y estaba todo el día en casa
y adonde iba a barrer a limpiar a hacer
venir llevaba su radio y yo tengo tantos
recuerdos de mi abuela escuchando la
radio la w la radio w yo sigo escuchando
la doble o radio cuando trabajo en la
mañana en mexico es es es linda la radio
te permite conocer te permite estar y yo
he vivido cosas muy particulares con la
radio no para trabajar tan como el papá
de elvis también trabajaba en la radio
durante muchos años trabajó en la radio
y cuando le había dejado trabajar
después se dedicó a otro tipo de
trabajos y cuando ya estaba jubilado
tenía cosas que hacer por ejemplo el fin
de semana le ponía mi mamá a escuchar
los partidos de san lorenzo y mi mamá le
anotaba las estadísticas muchas
compañías a mi mamá sentada con un
papelito y un lápiz anotando quién hizo
el gol cuántos pases todo eso
la radio era parte de nuestra vida bueno
guarden recuerdo tarde recuerdo porque
la semana próxima se la vamos a dedicar
todas a radio canadá internacional ya
eso es recuerdo otro mensaje de leonard
yo tenemos mensajes juan carlos miranda
duarte y saludos luis valdez e muchos
saludos desde san antonio hace poco
recordamos el día mundial de la radio y
les mando un saludo realizado por su
nuevo aniversario 75 años después se
creó el servicio en español saludos para
cada uno de ustedes juan carlos miranda
duarte y se felicidades
javier gonzález nungaray dice me da
mucho gusto y una felicitación a ersa y
por sus 75 aniversario y que cumpla más
yo escuché el último programa
transmitido por pablo en onda corta
maría herrera dice saludos de san luis
argentina lo sigo permanentemente
felicitaciones hugo bbc dice saludos
desde santiago de chile hugo lópez es el
nombre de este seguidor miriam alarcón
dice yo sigo escuchando radio en onda
corta y tengo una tonomac super p latino
es siempre que puedo la presumo es una
no poder adjuntar una foto feliz
aniversario gustavo lucas dice saludos
desde la ciudad de melo departamentos
enrolar un uruguay feliz aniversario
verse y el próximo martes recuerdo
siempre entre otros a susana pena de
puga cuando en el castor llamaban a los
oyentes recuerdo que conversé con pablo
hasta mi madre lo pudo saludar si javier
gonzález nunca nuevamente nos dice
saludos cordiales a paloma de
aguascalientes
reguera hidro calentanos hidrocálidos
iván carlos miranda dice yo escuchaba
desde niño en radio canadá por onda
corta radio tuvo a bueno que bien
excelente cae muy bien todos esos
comentarios porque justamente los
queremos invitar que vamos a hacer un
programa especial va a estar dedicado
completamente a los 75 años de radio
canadá internacional y el viernes
próximo y queremos que ustedes
participen que ustedes nos envíen fotos
vídeos audios donde nos cuenten algo
sobre radio canadá internacional como lo
descubrieron que les parecía en esa
época que les parece ahora porque no
estamos en lo mismo y tenemos mucha
gente que nos dejó de escuchar porque
hubo esa transición de la onda corta al
internet y entonces pues no no fue
apreciado ese cambio hubo algunas
personas no acuerdo con mensajes
específicos de gente que decía ah no yo
no no es aunque ahora estamos viendo que
a lo mejor sí
bueno entonces los queremos es creer más
denos mándenos artiz y participen en
este programa cálidos o no que sean de
en donde estén y buenos díganos cuáles
son sus recuerdos de radio canadá
internacional vamos a conversar de eso
acá y ya veremos ahora en el transcurso
de la semana que forma que otra forma le
vamos a poder dar a esa participación
que ustedes van a tener aquí en ese
programa tan particular que es el del
viernes próximo para los 75 años de
radio canadá internacional aunque tengo
que aclarar que en la ddi la fecha es
del martes 25 de febrero pero lo vamos a
festejar aquí entre nosotros cerrando la
semana cerrando la semana
pobre tú te vas a perder
bueno y ahora sí ya que las invitaciones
están cursadas hay que ustedes están ya
al tanto de lo que queremos que ustedes
hagan y que nos digan sobre radio canadá
internacional regresamos aquí al estudio
porque tenemos a nuestra invitada cada
carmina en la que nuevamente no me canso
de decirlo estamos encantados de poder
conversar con ella y una de las razones
caras por la cual tú estás aquí es que
tú eres ilustradora entre otras cosas es
ilustradora porque además de ilustradora
tú haces debut con cosas y así también
encarnó muñecas en fin tú no vas a
explicar todo eso pero comencemos por
esto de estos libros que están recién
salidos calientitas hace dos semanas
salieron salió el que tiene louis porque
este es una sorpresa exhale hasta mayo
pero para abril es una serie entonces el
primero es el de paula
el libro está en francés pero el título
en español es pauline la conejita sin
cola
y es una serie que habla de la
intimidación en las escuelas de cómo
aproximarse con los niños hablar de
cuando uno es diferente cuando te
sientes fuera de contexto y yo que
trabajo con niños chiquitos lo veo mucho
mucho y de frente y por eso quise hacer
esta esta serie con los conejitos y
viene a salir así que me da mucho gusto
que los tengan con ustedes son amigas
pero ahora este libro estos libros me
recuerdo que todavía se ha hecho algo
con una actriz quebequense no recuerdo
en este momento su nombre
sophie fosse de las entrevistamos
justamente en momento de adona con el
libro de frida sí entonces y en ese caso
en lo de frida ella escribía el texto
pero ahora en este caso de acá de pollin
y theodore creo que eres tú la que está
hablando como escritora y para mí es un
gran sueño hecho realidad es mi bebé es
mi proyecto yo escribí la historia yo
hice todo el concepto toda la
ilustración
la primero es que se me da esa
oportunidad aquí en quebec y estoy muy
contenta que lo tengas en tus manos es
fácil para los escritores de otros de
otros orígenes hacerse camino no
entonces me imagino que ha sido un
cuéntenos como como fue bueno este mundo
mujeres que son inmigrantes llegar a
quebec acá no es no es miel sobre
ojuelas siempre ya que hay que tú mismo
me decía sabes hace rato que trabajas en
la construcción de mi primer trabajo y
para mí fue eso fue el primer reto fue
aprender el francés yo llegué hace 10
años a quebec y el francés fue lo que me
abrió muchas puertas mi primer libro
infantil como ilustradora lo hice en
argentina con una editorial que maccabi
está libros copio y bueno el primero a
café con sophie fue con la editorial
editó que habla de la vida de frida
kahlo son dos tomos pero definitivamente
la abrirme camino como ilustradora en un
lugar donde yo soy totalmente ajena a la
cultura con el mundo editorial es
complicado y mismo que ve que dentro de
canadá sabemos que es una situación
cultural bien particular
y bueno fui empezando como entrepreneur
mis ilustraciones yo las empecé haciendo
muñecas como bien lo comentabas hace
rato y vende productos de con mi trabajo
hice muchas cosas antes de hacer los
libros y ese es ese proceso que fue un
poco a la reversa me ayudó mucho a
entrar al mundo editorial más o menos
eso es como como yo me abrí el camino en
el mundo de los libros y te ha
diversificado también o sea porque está
lo de las muñequitas estás que tú haces
que son muy muy muy bonitas y además de
eso están los leggings
bueno es lo que yo te decía tengo muchos
productos entre ellos una línea de ropa
los leggins fueron como muy muy
populares populares sí y a mí me gusta
mucho como diversificar mi trabajo
porque como el historiador no es fácil
ganarse la vida yo gano 100% mi vida de
mi trabajo de ilustración pero no es no
es a veces dibujar no es cualquier cosa
y las muñecas vinieron antes de mis
ilustraciones yo empecé a son muñecas en
méxico y cuando me vine aquí en 2009
continué pero empecé hacer
de frida kahlo y a la gente le gustaron
mucho y fue así como conocidas o fifa yo
ya vi a mis muñecas de frida y me dijo
un día tú y yo vamos a hacer un vídeo
porque hay que decir que eso fifa se
había interpretado el personaje de frida
anteriormente se conocía ese personaje y
le llamó la atención que tú estuvieras
trabajando con este personaje a través
de muñecas y después de dibujos etcétera
entonces fue así como pero no fue al
revés te crees que fue al revés entonces
siento que fue pues te diré conozco
muchos ilustradores que de a partir de
sus ilustraciones empiezan a hacer
muñecas hay mucho ilustrador que hace en
jackass yo conozco a varias amigas tengo
amigas en méxico en el mundo pero a mí
fue al revés mismas e ilustraciones son
muy reconocidas por los ojos con
estrellas adentro y yo eso lo hice en la
máquina de coser la primera es que yo
dibujé ese personaje fue con hilo negro
en la máquina
y después se tradujo al papel entonces
es un proceso bien bien extraño
que hay otros personajes que vienen así
y bueno justo justo justo hoy acabo de
terminar el tercer libro de escribirlo
en falta dibujarlo de esta serie que se
llama le lapan mal a la editorial
ese editorial edición lema la y entonces
creamos esta serie para hablar de la
intimidación del bullying inglés de este
tema que a mí me preocupa mucho y bueno
si justamente voy a voy a hacer la
primicia acá de que ya viene el tercero
y hable un poquito del halloween y del
día de muertos por ahí ese es el tema
sale en septiembre pero bueno el polín
ya está ya está librerías está
disponible también en línea y theodore
salen mayo
y hoy hablábamos también del cambio
tecnológico en los medios de
comunicación y en el caso de los libros
para niños supongo que debe ser todo un
desafío y competir con lo que son las
nuevas tecnologías te has planteado el
tema bueno para mí las tecnologías han
sido gran ayuda
yo soy gran amante del internet y son
mucho mis redes sociales posteo casi
diario invierto muchas horas de mi
tiempo en hacer redes sociales y me
gusta y es por las redes sociales que he
conocido y ha tenido experiencias
increíbles con otros ilustradores con
editoriales con otros escritores mi
libro que publiqué en argentina con el
escritor germán machado que es uruguayo
elbio mi trabajo en internet y fue así
que nos conectamos hicimos un libro a
distancia yo jamás he visto a germán de
datos
exactamente en español es una es poesía
infantil y es editado en argentina y fue
el último libro en español fue el
primero y el último
que el bullying no es un problema que
existe solamente aquí o sea que
probablemente todas estas obras pueden
ser también acompañarnos de méxico que
la boca aceptará chicharrón que si se
cumple ese deseo porque eso es lo que yo
quisiera que mis libros se trabajarán en
más idiomas el de frida está en italiano
en coreano y en francés europeo ese es
el que ha tenido como ha abierto más
puertas y espero que pauline y teodoro
lleguen muy las escribiste justamente
escribiste en español o en francés esto
yo viví esto en inglés y un poco en
francés y es una persona que quiero
mucho me ayudó mucho con el francés anne
y llegó y hicimos el texto porque me
franceses es bueno pero no
suficientemente bueno para escribir
completamente sola sabes pero pensé que
habías escrito en español gracioso que
perdés que viene inglés se tradujo
curioso
en inglés se me da muy bien escribir en
inglés me gusta y bueno ni siquiera me
lo cuestiones lo escribí en inglés casi
el casi usaría yo decir casi tu primera
segunda lengua
total si yo hablo inglés es desde
pequeña méxico y vemos una escuela
bilingüe mi hermana yo entonces a mí él
el inglés se me facilita lo tengo de
hace mucho tiempo y también para el
editorial con la que trabaja era mucho
más fácil revisar mi texto en inglés que
en español porque aquí hay gente
anglófona en inglés pero es un poco la
gente que habla español
entonces fue más bien una cuestión de
logística para la editorial también para
entender la historia que quería contar y
todo lo planificado también una una
contrapartida en inglés estaremos el
texto está en inglés entonces es
cuestión ya se son diligencias entre
editoriales y eventualmente si hay esas
noticias se les hará y en español
hay pro proyecto para que salga en
español porque no todas las personas que
nos están escuchando
pues yo espero te digo esto ya es
cuestión de es como dar a luz un libro y
dejarlo que salga y ver hasta dónde
llegan a leonardo hay algún comentario
por ahí sí y se las flores y se díganle
a mi prima paloma que él habló mucho
felicidades
y césar rodríguez xavi dice qué bonito
trabajo felicitaciones gracias y bueno
pues nosotros estamos aquí contentos más
contentos que perro con dos colas como
de la vida por un perro con dos colas y
está con nosotros de nuevo tenemos otro
dicho en colombia en barranquilla entre
otros sin william y william y está por
ahí sí entonces que dice que más
contento que marrano estrenando lazos
bueno estamos contentos bueno seguimos
acá vamos a seguir conversando con cara
carmina y en el transcurso del programa
que nos quedan
11 minutos pero antes de continuar si no
hay otro mensaje mi querido leonardo
nos gustaría que conversáramos de otro
tema
y paloma y me dirijo directamente a ella
es que estamos haciendo acá en en radio
canadá internacional una serie una nueva
serie de podcast y es paloma la que está
iniciando esa serie en español
entonces háblanos un poco de eso paloma
estoy muy contenta pablo de ser la de
ser la que está iniciando esto porque yo
escucho mucho podcast tú sabes que los
podcast es como la radio yo por eso
siento que los podcast son como la
continuación de lo que es la radio lo
que es la radio hoy en día como consume
la gente los productos auditivos como lo
que producimos aquí en radio canadá
internacional entonces esta serie trata
de ir a buscar y a descubrir a
científicos canadienses de origen
latinoamericano que están haciendo
investigaciones de primera línea de
punta y que nos cuenten lo que están
haciendo y la importancia que están
teniendo dentro del panorama científico
canadiense estarán mucho aprender
tal vez es saber qué grandes científicos
de origen latinoamericano realmente
manejan laboratorios completos
departamentos enteros de investigación
en todas las en todas las áreas o en
todas las áreas desde las matemáticas
más puras y más abstractas hasta las más
puras bueno proyectos en medicina en
ciencia aplicada
en medio ambiente entonces en esta serie
les presentamos justamente las
diferentes facetas de estos científicos
es una serie que comenzó este lunes
pasado con la investigación de una de
una costarricense canadiense que tiene
una beca ahora gigante que acaba de
recibir del gobierno de canadá y tiene
un laboratorio enorme a su azúcar a su
cargo y a su cargo ella es la que lo
maneja se llama laboratorio arrieta y ya
se llama marie claire arrieta es ella la
dirigente en el en la universidad de
calgary en alberta y bueno si la ve en
la serie hoy es el pcpe se difundió el
pri el quinto episodio perdón y la
próxima semana de 12 episodios más y
cada uno cuenta la historia de un
científico diferente y no solo
entrevistas solamente mías son
entrevistas de todos los miembros del
equipo has hecho tú algunas de las
entrevistas de carrión ahora otras louis
otras yo entonces para que escuchen y es
un montaje tipo radio como antes que nos
contaban las historias entonces las
escuchamos nada más así osea dejaron de
vivir como entre bueno siguen viviendo
como entrevistas
pero es otra presentación digamos que es
un nuevo vestido exactamente con sonido
con música con narración entonces que
las vayan a escuchar que las bajen a sus
teléfonos y que las escuchen tiempo rcn
puntos
así que los invitamos muy cordialmente a
que vayan a nuestro sitio y escuchen
porque son verdaderamente muy buenos
esos podcast muchas gracias paloma y en
luis laborda y eso tú nos hablas de dos
canadienses que estaban a la deriva
enfrente de las costas pacíficas de
colombia si dos canadienses que fueron
rescatados ayer jueves que zarparon el
15 de enero del puerto de los ángeles
con su yate particular que se llama
'decepción' y se dirigían hacia panamá
pero cuando estaban a la altura o
habiendo pasado ya costa rica en una
escala que hicieron en su trayecto les
falló el motor y entonces
a la deriva en alta mar y tras cinco
días de búsqueda la armada colombiana
los encontró a 104 millas náuticas del
puerto de buenaventura el principal
puerto en el pacífico columbian
muchísimo pero los tres gatos sanos y
salvos los dirigió a tierra firme les
dio de comer etcétera y allí en esta
información que nos suministró nuestro
colega martín movilla tenemos
información que produjeron las
cuadrillas de rescate los propios
náufragos que se filmaron en alta mar
que relatan qué es lo que pasó y lo
cierto es que estas dos personas los dos
canadienses de 63 años de edad están
sanos y salvos
disfrutando el primer color en este
momento que es un poquito más cálido que
el que está haciendo el momento aquí en
canadá y que pronto podrán seguir con su
travesía una vez que la embarcación sea
reelecta en gasolina al carro
y aventura bueno pero hay gente que es
un poco en su yate que hay muchísimos
aquí en canadá que hacen lo mismo le
pasa que tuvieron este problema de que
justo en altamar el motor de propulsión
como dice el comunicado oficial de la
armada canadiense perdón colombiana
fallo
justo ocurrió esto de un día que no
había viento y dejó entonces la
embarcación quedó semi parada en altamar
porque el no haber viento no informa de
que ya te siga avanzando sin motor y sin
vientos no hay forma con remos no
alcanza esta tarde un yate y pedalear
así que pero en un momento empezó a
soplar el viento en ráfagas bastante
fuertes entonces los empezó a impulsar
hacia el sur y es así como fueron
descubiertos en definitiva en aguas
territoriales colombianas pero era un
velero no no era un vélez un sastre ya
ya
emergencia hay que soplar muy fuerte no
me daría pegadita la costa
alta mar así
sea ahí pueden encontrar la historia de
la que nos está hablando luis laborda
leonardo gimeno tú nos hablas de un
viaje orbital para turistas y para
turistas de mucha plata
paseo exacto también no se sabe cuánto
va a salir pero ya están abiertas
digamos las las solicitudes para ver
quiénes pueden pagarlo primero y si
quienes tienen ganas de ir a hacer un
viaje orbital que depende de space x
esta empresa de los más el propietario
de paypal y otras cosas más que bueno en
esta carrera espacial que espacial
privada
es esta empresa y otras dos que están
compitiendo también son otros dos
millonarios que tienen ganas de ver en
esta carrera entonces lo que hace space
x en este caso es ofrecer en uno de
estos cohetes nuevos la posibilidad de
hacer un viaje aquellos que tengan el
dinero para pagarlo
dentro de un año y un año y medio
aproximadamente el 21 2022
fines 2021 principio 2022 para cuatro
personas que puedan para costearse y
cuánto duele el pasaje todavía no se
sabe pero lo que hay informaciones de lo
que pasó antes y antes otra de las
empresas se había puesto en venta
también un lugar para hacer un viaje ni
siquiera orbital pero para viajar en
realidad en una de estas naves y salía
nada más que 52 millones de dólares lo
caro
y la libertaria dueño del circo del sol
así que la información sobre esta
propuesta de viajes orbitales por space
ex pueden verla en el sitio internet
bueno es fantástico porque me parece que
aquí la libertad no había sido tan caro
su paseo bueno fue una cápsula soyuz
rusa que estuvo allá pero estuve en
estación en la estación espacial
lamentablemente no tenemos rebaja por
ser tu tablet yo pues mira quiero
invitar a todos los que nos están
escuchando en este momento a que visite
nuestro sitio porque entre otras cosas y
entre aparte de los podcast también
estoy este este mes de febrero se está
celebrando el mes de la historia de los
negros en canadá y nosotros tenemos un
expediente bastante completo sobre la
historia de los negros en este país
entonces
van a tener una idea de cómo es que la
población afro canadiense llegó aquí
cómo se formó y tenemos una serie de
reportajes en español claro está también
está en inglés en francés en árabe y en
chino pero nosotros pues los invitamos a
que vayan a visitar los distintos sitios
y ustedes desplacen y en español en
particular donde van a ver de personajes
que de la historia
el canadiense que nosotros conocemos muy
poco y que bueno pues marcaron gente y
también del cliché también del presente
exacto si eso es lo bonito de este oeste
entonces pues eso es lo que yo quisiera
yo quisiera invitarlos y se nos acabó el
tiempo tenemos que regresar a nuestra
invitada
[Música]
gracias por invitarme y gracias a todos
los que nos escucharon y nos vieron
síganme en cara carmina en instagram en
facebook mi sitio cara carmina puntocom
para que vean todo lo que hago muchas
gracias por la invitación para comprar
en la estancia si se puede comprar en el
sitio de la editorial muy bien en los
controles técnicos soy leo bélanger lee
y el infaltable diario tu piel
el gran peter y bueno pues fue un gran
placer estar reunidos con ustedes aquí
en el estudio como ustedes allá del otro
lado del micrófono y de las cámaras para
este viernes de
en las américas
[Música]